but I love this choice for you because
this isn't the kind of movie that fits
into a category and political films are
not always the easiest sell but after
gravity I would imagine you could have
done anything you wanted what was it
about this that it got you most excited
it's I mean you have gravity which
became something that I don't think any
anyone involved with gravity expected I
mean literally up to the last minute no
one thought it would do well and that's
you just never know sometimes you think
something's gonna be a huge success but
it was this otherworldly experience on
so many levels the making of it and then
the end result in and when something is
that big you have to step back and just
go away and just take it all in I didn't
want to not enjoy every moment of what
that film gave me and my life had become
drastically different because I have
this beautiful little boy and I was like
I had this great experience now I'd like
to have the experience of being a mom
and just being present and and so when I
started to look I wanted to do something
drastically different you're given this
blessing of gravity and so many things
that came with it
I felt I had a need and an opportunity
to push an envelope somewhere while
looking for great material and I just
wasn't reading it and I wanted something
to say something I wanted the great role
and I wanted subject matter that I felt
would be great to leave behind for my
son you know why are we not bringing up
certain issues that I think are very
topical while still making it
entertaining
so tonally I found I loved it because
life is very messed up like that because
no such thing as a day of mine without
some embarrassment and some tragedy and
some joy and and I felt like you you got
so many levels in this movie and it just
it landed on my desk at the time that I
was needing something bigger and I
wanted to be responsible for bringing
that to screen and giving myself a role
opportunity that I wasn't getting is
wonderful as the opportunities are they
just weren't the things that I was like
the guys get to do it I want to be able
to do it too
and given the fact that as many of you
probably know if you've heard any of the
coverage of this film given the fact
that your character was originally
written
a man which is weird cuz you don't hear
many guys named Jane just get off but no
but I'm joking but so here it was James
oh oh there you go so why did why did
the script end up on your desk in the
first place was it for the endowed role
I mean was it no I I we were
purposefully looking at scripts that
were out there that had great subject
matter in fantastic characters that were
written for men that we would then read
and and hopefully go back to the
producers and beg for the opportunity to
steal it away from a major movie star
George Clooney so but it was the only
one that really resonate there was some
other comedy scripts that were fun but
nothing that really felt like I need to
now spend my time on this uproot my son
go somewhere else and just dive into
that and I've heard you say also that
you found that anything that's a female
role lead female role that's a comedy
the comedy is around her love life it's
and nothing else it's all always around
chasing the guy and this is so different
from that which is exciting it's it's in
the comedy isn't slapstick it's it's in
it's it's like life it's like you don't
want to look at it it's an someone is
just dude it's it's she's doing things
that are not great and she's getting
stuck between a rock and a hard place as
she should and you I want you to be able
to laugh at her because there's so many
people as we know in this climate that
are behaving interestingly in truthfully
and it makes for good comedy Anthony
when I was writing my notes for this
panel today I wrote that your character
Ben seemed to me like the moral compass
of the film and then I read an interview
where sandy you called him the moral
compass of the film so it did you did
you think of it that way was that part
of the appeal did you ever consider
yourself almost like a surrogate for the
audience in any of the scenes Thank You
sandy for that no it was um you know
when I read the script it was
interesting I thought he was just a
character with a lot of integrity and
dignity and I feel like you never get to
see that in politics I feel like every
time you see that you know political
figures like oh he's a scum bucket he's
a swashbuckler he's a bad guy and you
never they're actually people in
politics who really care about how the
politics effects
the people of the world and then kind of
I believe was one of those guys I love
the idea of David Gordon Green as the
director of this film for those of you
who aren't aware he's done everything
from like really beautiful intimate
character pieces like all the real girls
in George Washington and the classic
pineapple and pineapple Express so it's
a tamir Award nomination for pineapple
which categories I'm gonna ask you which
categories later why did he stick out
for for you as the as a great choice for
this you know we were we were looking
for a director for a while we we met
with a bunch of people and you know as
you see it's this film is not an easy
tone it really you have to be able to
sort of dip into a bunch of different
areas and that's the thing what you
mentioned about David is he he makes
these beautiful if you haven't seen any
of his smaller films snow angels and
there's there's George Washington dirt
oh yeah they're just they're like these
beautiful little gems and they tug at
your heart and and they're just
beautifully made and then if you see
pineapple Express which I'm sure many of
you have and then he also did a show on
HBO called eastbound and down and they
are raunchy and funny and irreverent and
so this just seemed like this seemed
like the perfect sort of mix for him and
he was looking to sort of put all that
together so that's we met with them and
Sandy and I we fell in love with him I
had worked with him before we had
developed oddly enough a John Grisham
piece so that was odd for both of us
actually and so I knew him a little bit
but when we got in the room and then the
other thing was that he knew New Orleans
really well and you know both of these
got we we could only shoot in New
Orleans because well because you know
sandy has a house there in Anthony has a
house there so my son could go to school
there I was like that I'll feel good
about being on set if I know that he's
New Orleans is a great place to shoot
because you get great rebate and had all
and then there's the food and you know
if you get a chance to go for the food
good so I want to take a step back and
talk about changing the
again so when when Jane became Jane you
work with Peter Strahm who's a great
writer who did Tinker Tailor Soldier Spy
what is involved besides going through
and changing the name and adding some
sexual tension between the pack handy
role in the Jane role what else switched
up you know there wasn't there wasn't
much to switch because originally there
wasn't there was no that dynamic didn't
exist you know because it was packed
candy and I forget the guys name let's
call him James there there was no
tension there I mean there was tension
but it was different it was professional
tension and this was professional
tension but clearly he used his he used
to he used some history to really get at
her and that was really that was really
it you don't want it change that's you
know that's as a female you know I
always I was begging I love this role as
it is in me stepping into it please
don't change anything don't soften don't
you know make it cuter like you you you
really strive for material that's this
good and then somehow you find it
diluted along the way but this never
this never got diluted it was just the
the specifics for the scene were
adjusted they've been you know like if
we had to change a name or something for
legal reasons you know but that that was
it everything pretty much stayed the
same like which is what Idol fell in
love with in the first place boxers
instead of panties that guy did doing
this movie change the way any of the
three of you not only view politics but
view your own public relations in the
entertainment world because I think in a
lot of ways there are some similarities
how is it politicians are great actors
and performers but no it definitely
changed the idea for me that we never
get to see like I remember in ninth
grade when I found out the president had
a speechwriter I was like well as he's
reading somebody else's words those
aren't even his words you know like
civics blew my mind so you know I
remember that
day specifically and so this kind of
just reaffirmed that for me just the
idea of you know we want us we I feel
like America's calling out for someone
who's going to say what they're gonna do
and do what they're going what they say
they're gonna do you know and we just
we've we haven't seen that how about you
yeah I mean taking this film which you
know it's not easy to get made small
budget boulder uphill and we all
everyone who came on the movie came on
to it with this with different passions
I don't want to say politically but sort
of socially we all cared about certain
things in a very big way that all sort
of collided and came together and I
think that's why we all connected and
really light each other at the end
because we felt like you have a social
responsibility we're given this gift and
the arts to say things sometimes you
have to say it first and sort of be the
first one to prove it and then people
just kind of knock you about for it and
you're like but you still have to move
forward because eventually it'll be a
paved road and that's what I like about
the end of this film is that you you
just have to suck it up and not repeat
and that's what I think socially we're
experiencing now is that you we're
seeing the same cycle over and over
again and now the curtains been pulled
and we see it happen and we go oh my god
this has been happening exactly the same
way for how many years it's now time for
a fresh honest voice if that's not
polished
that's not managed to you know to a
homogenized level you just have to take
the risk and be authentic and I think
that's what we all loved about this zone
I think that's what we all feel
politically or I just don't like that
word politically because it feels like a
chess match I want what's good for our
country there's a lot of different
people in our country I all want them to
have their happiness I want my son to be
proud of what I've left behind I want
you know there's so much that you want
but I don't know I mean I've wanted that
before but I think now I see so much of
the dirty tactics that I'm like it's up
to me to make a small difference